before we get into the
ridiculousness with chappelle and malik
b
phoenix november 5th through the 7th
nashville november 19th through
21st and then just coming to the stage
boise idaho bubba baby it's gonna be
freezing let's snuggle up
one show one night only december 5th
hopefully we add another show there
december 5th is some theater out there
boise i've never been there i've no idea
where i'm going to be
but uh look it up tickets just dropped
the links on t5k.com right now
boise idaho is december 5th but before
that phoenix november
november 5th through the 7th and then
nashville's november 19th 21st
special guest will be at both those
shows so stay tuned
come and see us in phoenix nashville
boise t5k.com
thick boy merch just dropped we just uh
restocked
jerseys restocked thick girl stuff we
got the gorilla tees and hoodies
available all thick girl
uh gear socks we got the think boy uh
official jersey hats
shorts stickas we got it all man end of
the month we're dropping a new
dope uh merch for you guys so
thickboy.com for everything thick boy
related
that's thick with three c's anything
else is [ __ ]
thickboy.com this podcast is brought to
you
by a ton of alpha brain that i'm on
right now that's why my
mouth is moving so fast my brain is
moving so
fast despite cte shout out to alpha
brain
total gut health earth grow nutrients
protein powder
we got glutamine creatine we got it all
man how about you get yourself some
fitness gear kettlebells impossible to
find we got them in stock
you know on-demand training you're
trying to look for a gym forget about a
gym
do it out of your garage do in your
living room doing your hotel room comics
you can do in your hotel room when
you're on the road on it demand training
on it six body weight training anything
but you'll find ass self
you want maces quad maces steel maces
sandbags battle ropes you want uh gear
fitness gear for men women jiu jitsu
stuff
geez whatever man on it dot com slash
fighter 10 off
you're welcome uh what you're saying
about dip now
you're trying to oh you want something
no i don't want this [ __ ] no i did the
uh long time ago i did the red manchu
you know is that the tobacco leaves yeah
you actually chew it i could be into
that but what you do
is and i think a lot of baseball players
do this
um they what they do is they get
i love it they get um chew the
bubblicious up like get a
pretty big water and they put it in it
pack it in the bubblicious and then chew
it to give it like
oh flavor you never done that say laughs
yeah
it's i like that that doesn't make me
nauseous but like the
the [ __ ] can to the actual this and
then
spitting i yeah it makes me back i'm
like i can't do that
i don't know why but you have to spit if
you eat the the yeah you gotta spit you
guys
that i can't do that i think that's
where my girl would draw the line if i'd
like
spit cans around the crib yeah like oh
dude you're trying to drink it like [ __ ]
this one's [ __ ] good
these little i don't know it looks like
gum pouches or something
just chilling team patches nicotine
patches we got cleaners coming down
oh we get oh we do yeah hopefully soon i
know right brother
that's been here before that that has
been here forever
so they come once
i'd be into that red look at red it's
red is it red man and it's actual
it's actual like leaves right yeah yeah
red man because is it as
uh toxic as the like the actual chew
with the fiberglass in it that's like
the worst you can get
i don't know i don't know because it's
leaves it doesn't have all the
you got to realize i did this when i was
like 16. um
sorry a second pouches no no
he's talking about the red man too red
man chew is just a straight straight
true it's straight
and honestly it's a lot more messier
than i think and then your teeth are all
like
brown leaves yeah
oh man oh you gotta ah god dude
everybody say is that red man the rapper
no he wishes that yeah
that's it that's that [ __ ] right now
uh-huh that's what you want to get you
get that
maybe i'll get a little before i go to
montana i mean you're gonna try it
but it might be stronger than your the
two milligram thing you do
yeah you're right yeah i don't i don't
like like traditional chew that ain't
for me
oh bro what my girl was making fun of us
when we tried that uh
that spicy chip that hot shoe oh did she
do it
she did it how'd she do she because i
showed her the video she's laughing at
the episode she's like so hard
yeah you guys are [ __ ] and she she
makes like i can accept that
me too i was like yeah that's fine yeah
but she makes like spicy salsa from
scratch and like habaneros the salsa she
made that oh yeah you had tacos yeah
yeah
we did the taco tuesday that was pretty
spicy yeah
and that's mild to her so she can eat
spicy stuff so she's like i'm gonna get
one of those i'm like i get
i think they get on amazon so she or it
came yesterday when i came home
and it was there i'm like i should try
it she's like uh well
i go just do it and she goes well i
should just do it now i'm not waiting
like no just do it
so she was like just she was like
getting something ready like doing
dishes like
just give it to me it's not a big deal
ate it and then she's all and it's hot
and then she's like doing the dishes
she's like that's really hot and her
eyes start to water
and i'm like she's like it's not that's
pretty hot
and i can see the panic on her face
that's what happened to me yeah like
there's this panic we're like man i
might have to go to the emergency room
okay and then she's i
don't worry that's going to go away it
seems like you might have to rush to the
hospital but you don't okay
and then she goes what can i do i go try
almond milk she start drinking almond
milk that's a good
milk yeah and then i put an ice cube and
then she's like oh my god that is
terrible
and then i go i go like outside with
tiger to do something
i come back and she's on the ground
in a fetal position yeah she's going
she goes it feels like i got shot in the
stomach
i told you you want close [ __ ]
bro and then and then i'm watching
watching d with tiger and boston right
here
and i look and she's in the bathroom
throwing up really
the worst out of it yo i think i heard i
had the same reaction i
didn't go and i didn't wasn't like i
texted you leo he said man she ain't a
real mexican real mexican could eat that
then also
fix your roof
from louisiana so it's like don't get me
wrong you're spicy but i feel like like
a
full ghost pepper one of those real
peppers would be way worse
way yeah like those are like
i think you gotta have like a medical
team around or some [ __ ] if you're yeah
korean is cooked with like a lot of
spice don't oh it's tasty spice though
not like
crazy spice yeah so the type of spice on
the chip is like chinese spice it's like
sichuan where it's numbing it's painful
[ __ ] one that was a mulan character name
what i didn't know that's just one
yeah the side of my tongue went numb
like the like the sides were completely
numb
yes well mine got stuck
you know what i mean so like yeah it
could like i was like trying to like
swallow to get it down but like my mouth
was so dry it was like
and i write it up i filmed it i was try
i sent it to nick he hopefully was on
kingston because i was filming it and i
go no you can't drink anything that's
the challenge
she's like get the [ __ ]
so why why did y'all do that what was
the story behind that
it was like a viral challenge that was
going around and nick
brought in those chips you know how
sometimes white people like hey let's
try this crazy [ __ ]
that's what it was no yeah that's what
it was it's not why would you do that
when the homicide death rate is up in
los angeles
due to those chips
there's no music so we might be able to
but uh someone eating like the hottest
was it like a re what's the hottest a
reaper pepper is that what they thought
the ghost uh carolina reaper i think
that's
number one yeah is there is there
someone that can just like straight up
handle it yeah there's some people
really yeah they don't have this people
can handle that [ __ ] carolina reaper oh
hey oh [ __ ] oh there you go let me say
let me see eating food that's two years
ago
that one here uh the heat's 14. that's
crazy
lab so let me see that yeah do not see
anything in this video oh wow
do not what do you not try anything in
this video oh really hell no
his name's ellie b i try to follow
directions
hold on handsome fella
long hair don't care yeah i thought that
little door a little bit
[Music]
sure says reaper challenge green guys
wait is he that big i think he came to
one of our shows
oh my god so you gotta eat oh
i can't imagine this being you just sign
off something right you have to say yeah
because you're going to
possibly die you can walk you could die
from that you're pretty sure
yeah why would wait like the heart i
don't know
i don't know if you'll die but there's
definitely uh
i think i heard that people can get
ulcers from eating spicy foods
that's going to take a while right
ulcers i think it's just so they're not
liable in the long run
because even howlin raised their
spiciest um
seasoning you have to sign off before
they let you have it
so what's the app i have no idea look at
it i i can't imagine he's rethinking
life right there bro oh
my god he goes why did i do that oh my
gosh
i love the music playing as well it's
like sad
so bad does he drink anything no no he
doesn't drink anything oh she's about to
throw up
oh dude you'd be so [ __ ]
he set the camera up oh
please it has to burn coming back out
too
oh it has to that's right joanna i was
like you throw up
your whole throat's gonna be on fire
yeah so that's the hottest pepper that
carolina reaper so that's hotter than
the chip we did
yes i think so because that chip has
ghost pepper dust and ghost pepper
carolina reaper on it why you just
didn't clean the dust off
well hottest pepper the carolina reaper
keeps popping up
i just remember seeing these two guys
that the hot ones guys sean evans and
this guy
who's like a pepper eater and they were
just dying when they were in the paper
they were like traveling in a
car somewhere no it's not it's not fun
man
why would you do that i don't like sal i
like spicy stuff i don't like like
out of control i like tasty spicy i hate
sour [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] with sour [ __ ] sour what
you mean like sour cream
no that what huh no like sour candy and
[ __ ] bro this is
a sour cream
atomic warhead no how old are you i'm
28.
they might have been around yeah they
were around four heads
exploding head on it the packages were
dope yeah
they still make those i think they do
but it's not a sour anymore
i i seen it before i never had that man
yeah we had candy that would [ __ ] us up
yeah you know remember the poppers
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah
you still do that i think pop rocks
because now they come with a clear uh
foot that you dip in and lick the foot
oh really yeah why would you put your
toe in this
it's yeah it's like this big candy toe
and you put it in it
hell no hell yeah the best candy of all
time the pink starburst
that's yeah i don't [ __ ] with a lot of
candy though oh my
i guess sweet teeth oh i'll say yeah oh
i know we
last week we were talking about somehow
public schools and jay said we got a
bunch of [ __ ] because i said uh texas
has the best public schools
yeah okay i should have been more clear
where
the area that i was looking at has the
best schools not the entire
i'm not saying they're number one the
entire state it's an area in austin that
has the best public schools
uh but as far as like overall in the
nation they're not number one but
they're top ten i think they're what's
on this list i think the top who's the
top number one i think is
like top state yeah illinois is number
one
uh new new york chicago new york
illinois vernon hills illinois that
wouldn't be chicago no
uh rose city california pasadena that's
uh
sponsored oh nice [ __ ] tribe
just trying to seduce
you want to keep your number two pencils
short oh god illinois again
new york but this isn't like mid like
midtown new york this is
out there cincinnati scott uh
new york austin texas oh okay
a plus but here's the thing they're all
a plus so it's not that austin texas is
number nine it's they're all a pluses oh
that's so they're all great man people
need to calm down
you're like you're way uh yeah like
texas is number three gonna argue
36. yes i will say this though and i'm
with you guys i'm getting
sick of everybody [ __ ] on la i'm
getting sick
i i do it a lot of times i was like you
do it all the time
i do it uh newsome there's a big
difference between [ __ ] on our
government yeah and [ __ ] on the city
okay i love the city la's in my heart i
[ __ ] love l.a okay
la's the best city in goddamn america
okay we have the worst
governor in america though so there's
when i [ __ ] on la i'm [ __ ] on the
the laws and the [ __ ] that he wants he
wants to pass these bills he wants to
pass
and the lockdowns that's i i can't stand
newsom i [ __ ] hate him with a passion
and i love everybody
you guys know this i have zero hate in
my heart you sound like you campaigning
right now
listen i can't approve
hey yeah be cool man yeah but really
really
you want to compare la to rep nashville
or that like
overall yeah we want to talk about city
for city come on yeah we haven't
having rain what do you want to do man
you know three months talk about all the
great cities in l.a
you know pasadena's dope burbank's dope
hollywood yeah
oh yeah santa monica venice so load of
company all of it's
all of it's really cool there you go
no compton is cool wait no sounds
central they're talking loudly
out of it you're different today
i get to uh compton and like uh crenshaw
is
uh randy's donuts oh the [ __ ] uh
wait wait the one on manchester oh you
go oh mancha there's only one
so be cool it's but that's that's what
it would the original ones this is
the the iron man one oh the iron man
he's on uh uh
not manchester united right oh no man
that's the inglewood one i'm telling you
i go to that one dog
yeah that's that's englewood if you go
left could get a little dicey
so far away from compton no he said the
closest he gets to call oh
gosh oh so i'm so far away
i'm about to say well hold on now now
they have a few i know there's one in
century city because my kid always asks
for a doughnut there
there's one pasting they just opened
they're okay there's a bunch but the
point is
uh the inglewood one's the one that was
featured in iron man and that's the
famous one
and i go there yeah oh my god my dad's
so funny he like whenever he comes to
like vacation in california
he only stays in the hood he stays like
in that area just stay in a motel
uh he said yeah i don't know bro one
time he had me meet him in a parking lot
yeah your dad can stay with me i know
right
with me
one time he stayed at this motel six in
eagle wood that was like popping
it was a motel six that was popping the
one the one
you know what i'm talking about i know
what you're talking about i think you're
talking about like the one by the way i
think it's
like what was that sent to lut no not i
don't know
imperial highway imperial imperial it's
right off the let's right off the
freeway it's emotional
it's still popping
hustle store marathon now let's shut
down that i got a barricade they have a
barricade okay
but but huh if you just go a couple of
blocks will they sell it off anymore
nah you can buy it online you can buy it
all you can say
there's no brick and mortar store there
anymore why because too many people like
come on
they're trying to buy that shopping
center and there and nipsey owned it so
they're trying to like literally take it
away so the city just barricaded and
just
shutting it down so now they have the
nipsy mural and they have like people
like still come over they have fried
fish they have it's still a celebration
but they're really trying to move them
out the way so they can buy that man
like newsome
see man
bro hell yeah but it's weird because
nipsey owned that that [ __ ]
he was mine yeah he was mine yeah yeah
and you don't want to know funny story
how you owned it
the guy uh when he they used to hang out
in front of the store all the time
well that's right yeah yeah right in
front of the store they murdered
and they was like yo listen you can't
keep hanging out they why don't you just
buy it this is the new
oh and he was like oh okay yeah and he
started like like let's talk let's start
talking about entrepreneurship
and nipsey like all like listen yeah
let's make make your money make money
and he just like took that idea then he
had homies in the hood
i'm not about to hire some employees
somebody had my homies give them a job
get them off the street and work the
store and he get killed
yeah hell yeah he was better than the
empire exactly
what you need man he's like he fixed up
that school over there
yeah a ton of money other schools gave
back to those schools yeah didn't want
to move to like calabasas or somewhere
else donated uh
a lot to a high school yeah he was a
billion though you know so
like donate dr dre yeah
exactly don't you donate to denver huh
yeah there you go aurora aurora that's
where you're from
yeah okay all right shout out to the
streets you donate to a road
if i had a billion i don't know if i
donate there though
you wouldn't donut they need it they
need it
they're not doing great
my mama still didn't though you have a
nipsy being killed such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
man
that was like your guy that is like he
was the guy this thing he was the guy
it was it was one of guys that like i
saw like real gangsters cry
oh dude he cried yeah and then i was
like damn that's that's tough that's why
because
it's like that's when really gains like
it's like man we're about to stop this
gang war we about to really
yeah there was there was gangs that had
like years of rival
rivalry stopped squashing they stopped
it for like three weeks
and then retaliation here's the thing
what who who well you know
obviously his girl and they have a kid
together what's your name
shout out to such a baddie yeah who's
gonna date her
well i don't want to get into that what
are you gonna do i don't know
you can't come behind that initially
what are you gonna do yeah i think the
best you can shoot on the low
yeah i think she should say with like
kobe bryant's wife like who's gonna
what yeah the black mamba yeah you can't
follow that league oh that yeah that's a
tough shot
like jordan or some [ __ ] you know that's
that's oh that's the enemy that's the
enemy why would she go to the enemy
he said he said jordan
imagine jordan of all the names you
could have named
one player better than him the one guy
but like i'm just staying on basketball
players
she's gonna have to just lay low like
obviously she has needs eventually she's
gonna move on
i think that if they do that they don't
need another man to just date another
woman
what huh she doesn't think about it
think about it wait time out time
you're going to get so much slack and no
now i don't want to increase
keep it private though well yeah but
like whatever eventually it's going to
be talking about you know
you're awesome you got to do it like
elon musk did with johnny depp's girl
come late at night midnight strolling
they're going to catch you
eventually they're going to catch elon
musk was dating johnny depp's woman he
was
he got caught he got caught that's what
i'm saying so what do you think
listen you're going to get caught it's
again i know i'm in basketball but if
it's like a really like let's say he was
single let's say it was like steph curry
no one's even like what the [ __ ] like if
it's a good dude how many steph curry's
are out there for laura london i don't
know dude
that's where he's a great guy by the way
great guy super nice that's why
that's the example yeah i helped him
with his go ahead go ahead no i'm saying
i just dropped his car
no i helped him with his luggage he was
so nice and he just kept calling me sir
and i'm like did he tip you well
oh yeah yeah come on this is this is i
don't know you never know
well-mannered well-mannered yeah
i'm a fan but it's gonna have to be
somebody like yeah that's that's a
that's i mean it's a tough act to fall i
don't even want to think about it for
him how do you know she even like like a
vanilla wafer
skin tone guy she like has light skin
yeah she doesn't like slight skin
i would say vanilla wafer yeah what
would you say
vanilla wafer i know we got a you know a
long battle we're talking about steph
curry not logic
yeah yeah you know that right there you
go okay
okay vanilla that's a good point
he's also he's not bad looking dude do
you think his uh wife is a hottie she's
all [ __ ] right
because she's such a hypocrite she shits
on aisha curry she shits on the girls
hair like oh yeah girl's like her right
there
she has blonde hair uh she's just
kidding you stay on the ground
look at that look at that right you
don't say on the ground not like that
i think she looks good i do too i mean i
post a lot of music and [ __ ]
oh she's cute what people are saying
she's uh she's not your vulture yeah
white people
no he goes both ways
you can't only be cornrows you know like
blonde here's our thing all right
like that's our thing we were born with
that yeah so
it goes both ways you we were born with
that
that's not true that's not true my
grandmother got
blind now no really yeah but she wasn't
born with blonde hair
my grandma got blonde hair and she was
not [ __ ] born with that there you go
shout out to grandma eula listen dye
your hair whatever color you want put
cornrows do
i don't give but beads i don't yeah
that's the least of my concerns
i know i don't give a [ __ ] but people
are coming out that's why they're coming
after her no
she called hypocrite well they call it
hypocrite because
she like talks [ __ ] about the instagram
models like showing like
their body and stuff like that and she's
doing it and then she was like thirsty
right bruh she i was in her dms when she
wanted to attention wait what what
oh yeah she had that remember that you
talking about yep uh yup she's talking
about like she was sad that guys didn't
give
her attention thank you
you was in there too using her dm's no
no
no she said yeah she was saying like
like it drove her she didn't feel pretty
because she wasn't getting the same
attention
as her husband steph curry the greatest
three-point shooter or shooter period in
the nba
she was getting the same attention
that's crazy
well she wanted yeah she wanted more
attention she wanted to like
like when she went out she wanted like
guys to like look back at her and stuff
like husband step three yeah well no
those dudes
listen women love attention we just
talked about it they got a car yeah
he's a good guy women love bad guys
let's just get that out the way okay
okay
so but they also like good guys they
also feel like yeah that's that good guy
hashtag good job
bad boys are short-sighted yep they all
end well act like it act like well but
i'm saying we get the first try
at the at the prize she never had she
never had a bad guy before
she was with me she was with
steph curry all the way through high
school oh the high school sweetie yeah
so she never experienced a bad guy so
she was what about what about your girl
uh
nipsey's girl laura linda had a baby she
was a couple of rappers a little wayne
before him there's the point fellas
is he a hashtag good guy no he's a bad
guy bad guy yes but he had the first one
he had
guy i'm saying by the way he was a bad
guy
too well well we'll have i don't know
that man business i don't want the 60s
to roll up on me
though yeah he's a good guy i'm saying
i'm saying you bad guys have the turn
first
at the women then the good guys come
afterwards because they're like you know
what bad guys i don't like being treated
like [ __ ] well bad guys aren't good
well sometimes what do they say you got
to go through the [ __ ] ruffle now
your friends no no i love that you gotta
kiss a bunch you gotta you gotta throw
chips you gotta kiss a bunch of frogs
before you get to the prince come on man
that's awesome
and then the frogs are tatted up
all right skipping on scissors jumping
to conclusions yeah kicking out a
windshield yeah
i'm talking about kissing a bunch of
other princesses
and you know what we call that a leap of
faith that's a leap of faith come on yo
why do people say yes to [ __ ] they know
it's [ __ ] up like well i feel like
people
like a person knows when they're in a
bad relationship they don't know
yes they do not ignore people i ignore
them
no if you know what they're fighting for
you don't have to say yes to everything
just about
man you ought to say yes but love is
blind you i love that
man were you in love
are you crazy think about the foundation
of how you met
think about that foundation how did you
meet the person hashtag good guy
that's a good guy hold on ladies and
gentlemen i'm gonna represent the bad
guys out here
ask your 60 year old 68 year old side
piece
he's still working back in the day okay
okay
you're 68 year old back in the day side
piece yeah
how many bad guys she's been through
because she's not a good guy she
wouldn't be
okay [ __ ] around with 24 year olds or
whatever you were yeah well it's 26.
and now listen let's get that out the
way she had
she had bad experiences yes but let me
just let me release say yes to every
single one of those
how long are you going to keep saying
yes until we get our [ __ ] together
until we get you getting the [ __ ] she's
exactly 60 hey
what she had wait for me to get my [ __ ]
together first
okay you don't understand bad guys you
good guys right y'all
y'all y'all are predicated like y'all
have a focus on
like repetition like you have your focus
you're driven
you straight forward you're a good guy i
am okay good guy
bad guys we're a hat we're i'm not a bad
guy by the way queen i'm just standing
in my back
so look but you could be a bad guy back
in the day now i would say mean bad guy
i mean like
you know talking are you talking yeah
yeah yeah exactly
yeah i don't mean like a bad person like
killing people stealing money no and
that
and by the way when we say bad guy we
talking about like the characteristics
bad boy bad boy yeah bad boy we should
say that a bad boy is like they can't
like you know cheat on women disrespect
women yes but never get physical
i don't get that no i was a player
because i realized that
one woman couldn't satisfy me right and
that's that's naturally you were young i
was young
and and and i was a bad boy but i didn't
understand like what
how that that affected these women these
women give their all in relationships
haven't you heard this song by john
mayer daughters no i didn't know
so when i had something yeah it's a
great [ __ ] song listen to that song
that's you [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry i'm a
good guy and i was getting rejected when
i was younger
because i was such a good guy i was
trying to follow i wrote a love album
for a girl
seven great songs seven
yep on my guitar love to hear it here's
the no i'm not
john mayer has gone through so many
girls i don't know if he's a good guy
i'm not talking about john i'm not
talking about john mayer i'm talking
about the song
he wrote okay i know but but like you
got to take it who's writing it why is
he writing okay now we got to go that
far no but we're
talking about the message yeah but if
it's a b but if the message is coming
from him it's like you know
i know a girl she puts the color inside
of my world
she's just amazed we're all of the walls
and continually change and i've been
done
all i can to stand on her steps with my
heart
in my hands okay now i'm starting to see
maybe he's going to do nothing this
isn't a rabbit it's got yeah maybe it's
got nothing to do with me
fathers be good to your daughters i
don't have a loved one but that's
it's just it's just about but bad boys
look like jared leto writing that you're
like what you [ __ ] everything in the
house
exactly okay serious
that's the only part though because he
does he's such as all these chicks
he had so much and that's and he was a
bad boy i hope we can jam one day
yeah you know what we call it great
okay listen you can call it fashion i'm
just bringing it out
okay but i'm saying everyone would you
rather me wrote write that down
no i wasn't that clever i'd feel better
about it you would feel better about it
i'm taking more serious
come on i can't stand when he sings that
song
that song oh daughters be good
tone it down tone it down with the
corniness
dude hey be less be less quality john
there
you called him a cornball you call him
john
i don't even know dude hey hater hey the
other crunchy thing is when he goes
in your bubble gum tongue
oh god dude
less cornball bubblegum
listen okay my point is yeah but bad
guys listen
so he might know that that that uh hey
they're delilah
another one yeah [ __ ] that song get
[ __ ] cooler man yeah i hate that
that's on cornball as [ __ ] hashtag
cornballs yeah you know that's that corn
headshot
you don't respect the message it depends
who it's coming from yeah well i don't
know those dudes
plain yt's by the way he was writing
about his friend's girl
so he had a crush on his friend's girl
or something so it's not good damn why
did these dudes jump into dumb
situations
like that what do you know r kelly
wrote uh a michael jackson song when he
was thinking about a high school girl
you're not you're not alone you know
damn what i'm talking about
that was a great song but our kelly
wrote it because
you like our kelly's messages i love his
music oh here's some jams
but like we know all right all right you
got
you proved you're [ __ ] yeah
how about r kelly got his ass beat in
prison he did oh yeah beat the [ __ ] he
got jumped
and my aunt and no one did anything no
really oh my god no one did
that protesting not in prison that don't
they don't yeah what are they gonna do
they said the guards and the
my dad my dad said that's a very serious
thing if you touch kids yeah
if you [ __ ] with kids you get destroyed
in prison 100
guards don't do [ __ ] yeah kelly's like
but she was 15
like in his ass mexican dude wore boots
that day
heard them you know when mexicans wear
boots that's that's still toast
his name is probably hector and [ __ ]
just [ __ ]
stomp you fools i'm pretty sure his name
was jason jason
yeah i wonder who did it but they said
they got pictures of them yeah you got
pictures yeah
they got a picture of him beat up yeah
yeah no no no no no you have to do go to
court the next day and his like face is
all [ __ ] up
no yep you know when mexican wear boots
that that means it's a prisoner right
nate says he was oh look at the inmate
yeah let's see the
picture of the dude the inmate says he
was forced to beat him up
tonight an inmate claims he snuck into r
kelly's jail cell
to attack the singer this is jeremiah
not jason i apologize
kelly was asleep in his cell at
chicago's metropolitan correctional
center last wednesday when he was
attacked
farmer in jail for racketeering
conspiracy right on the
all-out standard class card you know
it's like a flash card look at that
uh what do you think they don't have
pictures of r kelly
they will wait what does this say
a former with nowhere else to turn for
legal
help was forced to assault hip-hop rb
singer r
kelly uh hopes of getting spotlight and
attention
oh oh of the world near
does that say near world notice to shed
light on the government corruption here
in
whatever that jail circuit manly in the
united states yeah they beat him oh he
didn't care what r kelly did you just
wanted to get attention he just wanted
attention to shine light on that jail
it's bad see that's the thing that sucks
so he was a sacrificial lamb in jail
someone wants to
you but they usually do your favor and
put you in you know they don't put you
in general population yeah i know they
but he
but the fact that he's in like with the
regular people is just and then mexican
wear on boots they stumped them with
steel toes wait so did they have a
they had a crowd for him and he they
gave him a sentence i think now he's see
he's going through it right now going
through it right now
he's going through you heard what
happened to whitey bulger in prison
right who
whitey bulger whose car we taking what
are you doing oh whitey whitey you're
saying whitey whitey [ __ ] you said
wadi no
why do you why do you the guy from
exploited yeah whitey bulger
uh from black mass that johnny depp
played so they finally caught him in
santa monica right up the street from
here they come to santa monica after
like
14 years on the run yeah they caught him
and uh so they're they tried him in uh
prison in boston i forget where he
eventually went to prison but uh they
were transferred
to a gnarlier [ __ ] prison and an
inmate from a rival gang got a hold of
him
dog i think he was like 70 or like 75 by
the time he died
they [ __ ] that oh he died oh dude he
did a lot of stuff
get out his eyes right he beat him with
a lock yep
like he had a horrible death yeah bad
dude though man
bad bad dude i don't know this is true
it's a response of like hundreds of
deaths in boston
oh like we we glamorized like you know
like whitey bulger like uh
[ __ ] pablo escobar like escobar
killed thousands of people you're
talking about a straight up
terrorist dude yeah we glorify it
because of
shows like narcos narcos because he's
you get to know the character and you
can relate to the character and
you find yourself rooting for it for me
too some weird way but you look at what
dude you're talking about
he set off bombs in colombia they're on
the brink people
plane killed tons of people set off
bombs within the city like dude you're
talking about straight up
terrorists do you do this when you watch
movies so i watch gangster flicks and i
root for the bad guy and i turn it off
before it ends because a bad guy died no
no did i just run
what that was kind of hard a little bit
that was good afternoon yeah but no like
i root for the bad guy and i turn it off
before the end because i know the bad
guy's gonna get caught
or like oh oh like because i can relate
to the criminal
i can relate to like him like nah he's
just doing it because he have enough
money or he's doing it because
you relate to the camp like you have a
lunch move remorse like which character
training huh training day training day
washington yeah the rush russians all he
had to do was get the bag
and he delivered to the russians he can
be alive but jay want to shoot him in
his ass
jay i need this money jay jay
you did some loyal food
he shot me in my ass hey how about
my favorite part of that movie i wanted
the cardio's down i didn't know you like
to get wet
oh yeah
with the young white guy ethan hawks in
the car and he's like he's like where's
the office and then that dr dre song
hits and goes
you're in the office
the hardest line in there was like you
know i'm surgical with this [ __ ] jay
yeah
it's not good eva mendes is back there
with her kids getting back to him
he goes you know i'm surgical with the
[ __ ] come on man that was my favorite
part
we got to see man's name eva mendes was
his girl twice in
in a movie yeah yeah in a um out of time
out of time
great movie by the way he got some
classics he's got ganzo
me and michael michael turner boy
michael turner yes yeah
yeah so him and i have we've been
running a denzel marathon
his catalogue is
like i don't even pay attention to like
how long that movie is
[ __ ] because it's just like it's so good
it's so good it's like the beginning is
my job
i will not bury my son yeah my son will
bury me
yeah yeah right chin there's another one
uh save him titus dope too oh you
see philadelphia no i didn't see that oh
oh no i haven't seen that
aids yeah and he uh goes to like 21
lawyers before
finally denzel washington accepts him
dude that's are you serious he wasn't
even loyal because he's got eight
yeah back it's like in the 90s when aids
was popping like
people didn't really know what basically
magic johnson had it that's what was
good no but it's when like people were
dying left and right like it was just a
fight
and then if they thought you had it they
it's kind of like covet like they didn't
know if it was airborne or what so if
you had it
like people didn't want to [ __ ] with you
so he got fired from this big law firm
oh
because he has aids and like no we
didn't find him because he has aged he
farmed because
he did he wasn't doing his job but she
was like the top lawyer there
so he hires denzel to fight against that
firm it's so good
oh really so good gizelle is great when
he plays the lawyers did you
the pelican brief did you watch that one
that was great to see that one
the glory wouldn't matter the one that's
dealing with that's
him and uh ray allen were actually
playing basketball and they said denzel
was
dead serious and like made a shot and
was like damn i didn't and i started
talking [ __ ] though and rayon's like
oh you're serious and then they said he
busted his
ass
[Music]
you don't score again they don't put in
the movie goes but you don't score again
give them the ball and just
shut down denzel was like i didn't touch
the ball
for the rest of it like make it or take
it up to ten i didn't touch the ball
i don't think people realize how good i
was just about to say listen did you
hear about the time
when uh brian scalabrine uh what's his
name brian
from the boston uh
i think that's his name okay brian white
boy for the boston celtics yeah it's a
big
he's attract look told you he's so trash
right everybody he get like
like troll comments and all that he was
like i will meet you right now
in the goddamn gym and i will show you
so he met up with all his trolls
and he sucks in the nba he whooped he
whooped they ass ever yeah because even
if he's
exactly good people don't understand
yeah so i would go to the gym with him
and people because he won like
like he was in the dunk contest and he
was only known for duncan yeah
shots people at the gym were like oh
he's if all you got to do is make it
leave him open give him
leave just give him the shot like don't
worry about he can't make shots because
all he does is dunk
because you see him in the nba think all
he does is dunk
dude he didn't miss a [ __ ]
shot you would have thought it was steph
curry
but like people don't realize the level
of skill these guys had exactly
i'm telling didn't miss a shock did you
see the video with drake where
uh kevin durant blocks his ass all he's
doing i know yeah have you seen the
video kevin durant
back which bring up the video just
dropped yesterday kevin durant's in the
gym
oh he's looking keeley's looking fresh
oh really
that's why i don't troll these guys if
they're on their shots what about the
dude that was trolling uh
who did he troll well i do troll danny
green and he deserves uh that was
ridiculous he does
he deserve it uh well not his wife but
him i think there was a guy that trolled
uh
oh by the box oh deontay wilder yeah
yeah why don't we catch
that guy that's so that's what i'm
saying this is duncan again
that was seven months what was this yeah
what are you five days ago it's still
not him though oh lebron james yeah
yeah someone posted videos i've
you got too much dip on your chips yeah
too much
he's still doing his podcast with kyrie
irving yeah you're not worried about
basketball
everyone always said you know what else
is crazy everyone always said prince was
really good at basketball i saw on the
day chappelle show
yeah everybody said he was actually
really good yep he's about five
three right dude he was short yeah
crossing just i went
to the pace crossing dude
did you ever hear about when prince went
on uh saturday night live do you hear
about this
it was him and i think uh paul mccartney
and uh they were doing uh rehearsal
and they're like oh you you don't play
this part like that's not what you do
like your thing is this and he's like
excuse me and so when they went live
he just took over and like did the
nastiest riff ever
just dominated paul mccartney boys
really yeah i was like
i can play any instrument [ __ ]
wait hold on is that is that
is that a clip on that i'm sure it's
it's it's a famous clip
like they told him they told him not to
do something like that's a little out of
tune he's like excuse me yeah and then
just took over
like he wasn't supposed to play that
much at all and just [ __ ] took this
his first album he played every
instrument on the album
uh so gifted man um i would go to
do do prince and just uh snl it might
not have been palm beach i forget it's
someone
big oh wait wait wait you're talking
about uh
tom petty i forget you talking about the
performance he did with tom petty maybe
he did a performance at the time yeah
and he just went off on a solo like
wild yeah and he wasn't supposed to like
it's a classic story
it's a it's a yeah because i'm like damn
why is princess going so hard
typing prince tom petty i think it's
when um is it tom petty
tom petty while my guitar generally wigs
is it that
cause he goes off and then he throws
crazy about this
what's crazy about this performance when
prince is done going off
he throws the guitar in the air and no
one knows where the [ __ ] it goes
that's the craziest part david blaine i
don't know if the david blaine took it
but someone took it no i'm saying that
david
yeah go to where princess wait wait wait
prince is not even in this no what yeah
yeah he is watch okay keep going he just
come out of nowhere yeah he comes out of
nowhere prince is in there you'll see
him keep going
[Music]
there he is that's prince came out here
in the goddamn
harlem night suit you know he's
self-taught too yeah
yep dude he's dude i love he's a pure
genius
by the way what about what about it
raining when he played purple rain at
the the best lives
he died he got sick right he got sick he
said he was talking they said he was
touring
yeah and he was sick and they told him
to chill out and he kept going but
his daughter said they tried to they
killed him or something like that she
came out
daughter yeah his daughter french
daughter in atlanta daughter yeah 100
percent you could tell
i think you think of kurt covey no no
he's prince
he's prince prince his family member
came out
but i'm pretty sure i think it was a
sentinel thing yeah i think it was a
draw uh
yeah he took something and it was a
fitness i know you're like do you wet
you're right fentanyl overdose yep
painkillers man
you know that's the same way uh tom
petty
a lot of people yeah uh was it was was
that what got michael jackson too
that was no that was a sleeping
medication that his doctor gave him but
a lot of celebrities a lot of musicians
died from overdose from
uh homeboy who played dark knight the
joker he died
oh he left he mixed that with something
some other stuff i think anthony's
it was fentanyl that killed heath ledger
i know it's like painkiller type stuff
so
if you possibly can mixed it why would
you mix what
what would you mix it with you like to
party dude or you know he's trying to oh
he's trying to roll down
or was trying to come
and sleeping pills painkillers and
anxiety sleeping pills like when you mix
all of them so you like you get so
relaxed your heart just eventually just
stops
yeah uh he died at the
you know the next door to the comics
next door
i have a book on that that hotel it's
haunted like so many people
everyone said that i was like
sorry john belushi don't punch me in the
face for that
heroin cocaine and a speed known as this
i forget i forget who was with him uh a
girl
no but there's someone in his room uh
and then they laughed oh the mate
no famous comic was in kate was in the
room where you're thinking you're
thinking of a different situation
i think you're not you're thinking phil
hartman no i'm not no it's not evolution
because um i'm pretty sure either jay
let not make no it might have been
i forget who there's a really famous
person with him was in the room it was
like hey i'm going to leave man and
laughed
and then the next morning jim died he's
like what the [ __ ]
i was just with him it was a it's a big
time comic
it's and it's from that book uh dying up
here
oh it's a great show i thought you
talked about the books way better than
the show
it is the show makes it seem like like
everything was depressing
robert de niro oh robin williams so
robin williams was in the room because
robin williams like to get wet
so robin williams in the room and did
blow with him was like okay i'm gonna
take off doug
and left the room and then the next
morning mitzi was like
hey you know jim died and he's like john
he's like what the [ __ ]
i was just with him yeah really i didn't
i didn't know robert de niro but yeah
i knew robin williams was wow
crazy robert williams by the way lived a
great fantastic life
oh dude he was i i love his [ __ ] you saw
the documentary
i just did they have a documentary out
there it was like seven
yeah dude oh really yeah the big ones on
each other come on dog you're on the
you're on the ground all the time
uh yeah robin williams is itching it's
weird too because if you talk to like
old heads like
now that he's an old head who's in i'd
call him an old head he's been doing so
long like rogue and stuff yeah a lot of
people
i don't this isn't my words or rogans
i'm just saying
a lot of people when you bring up robin
williams will be like oh he's still bit
what oh yeah he was a performer he
admitted to stealing bits because
he would like he would see a bit and
then
they would they mimic things and like
movement behavior so he'd see the bit
and then he would take it over and then
people like oh [ __ ] dude that was
like my bit but you do and it's way
better than i did it but you'd take it
but he he addresses it too he's a guy
stole people's bid
and he's like i would get the idea and
then i would just elaborate on it
but once robin williams does your bit
like it's robert it's right
yeah you wouldn't know like that's the
same thing they did same thing happened
uh
to tripoli with uh ding cook oh really
oh he still talks about that does he i
don't know but he talked to him about it
oh so like like your comic comics we
talk about ron williams like ah
really stole bits alright can we talk
about his movies though this is
doubtfire i like to stand up better yeah
but he you know you're like jumanji i
love mr uh hold up i like
chill i like all his movies oh okay oh
but he's bad but
what happened here's the problem though
boys with a z
his best movie
hashtag good guys his best movie is
goodwill hunting
oh yeah
and he won i'm sure look it up best
supporting ben affleck and matt damon
won like the script or something
thank you they wrote they wrote that
they wrote the dogma
i'm sure they wrote a lot of [ __ ] but
goodwill honey gee that's the you've
never seen goodwill
no i would love goodwill i would okay oh
my god dude you would love it because uh
uh triumph story no because um
yeah there you go best supporting actor
who won the oscar because uh
what's uh matt damon is like he's
brilliant
he's brilliant but he has horrible anger
issues oh
oh you'll love him you would love it and
then because he goes to therapy and he's
never met a therapist
but robin williams is similar to him
yeah and they relate because so it's
kind of like my story with
you would love it dude
yeah for sure but here's the thing matt
williams not an aggressive way
it was kind of aggressive that's why i'm
trying to find your way i'm gonna find
your ass
hashtag good gosh
i get so aggressively happy about [ __ ]
you watch us with your girl tonight you
i bet you it's in your top five
oh really hundreds okay he can't find a
therapist that can
like that communicates with him and so
he just like they'll be doing something
like make fun of him so he keeps going
then he gets with robin williams and rob
williams
doesn't take any [ __ ] he's just like him
they're both in the same area in boston
really dude it's [ __ ] good he did win
best supporting actor robin williams i
didn't know
yeah my anger management teacher and i
connected because of music there you go
see him
because they're i was like from like
southie i think so they both relate
oh okay i gotta okay then i'll literally
watch it after after we're done please
do it and report back
let me let me know what you think i
[ __ ] hated school you
were milo are we putting that uh oh not
uh at the end uh
jay jay oh my god oh he shot
his ass he's all sweaty
play the player empty pen
i'm leaving you shoot me [ __ ] don't do
it
don't do it now i believe he got in the
chain
[ __ ] the money carlo's dope isn't it
so
don't do it you know what they give you
for that the gas chamber
you know what the gas chamber smells
like pine oil
that's where you headed boy to pine oil
heaven i'm gonna get that gun
and then i'm gonna get that money good
then you jake
i'm gonna go get it right now
son of a [ __ ] wait wait okay okay
oscar off his first oscar and people
people hate like oh he has to play a bad
guy before he wins the
[ __ ] like hashtag bad boy yeah all
right just
let the man act all right two yeah
he hasn't won one since right that was
the only one i thought he wanted
wait wait no he did business he didn't
win yeah he defenses right
i know viola davis won for viola davis
i don't think denzel did you sure that
was a great movie by the way but also
by the way august wilson oh he was so
cute nomination
category best he was up for it but uh
what happened
he should have won though washington
grabbed his first of five oscars and cry
freedom 1987 hashtag old school
uh he won best sport oscar for oh damn
he's one of few
you know who you know who what another
big snub was uh
val kilmer and tombstone playing doc
hollywood that was awesome too
that was great leonardo dicaprio got
[ __ ]
he should have won it so many times i
think brad pitt should have won it for
supporting but i think leonardo won it
for
lead in uh once once upon a time in
hollywood oh it was so [ __ ] funny but
they gave it to him for the research
what was the one with the best
runway doesn't talk yeah out of all the
the bears with the bear
yeah you're talking about reverend yeah
out of all the roles he never talks
you give him the oscar he did good
that's acting
did he really find your worst expression
something like that right
the bear [ __ ] him up tried eating his
ass ass first oh damn
he was just someone oscar they should
have gave leon uh oscar as well for the
role he did for temptations he played
definitely roughing i thought that was
david ruffin
shut up i thought that was david ruffin
bro he don't know ain't nobody coming to
see you oh yeah
coming out right now because the
production houses can't produce any
billions is coming up
right yeah shows are running or what
shows are outright blackish
oh yeah they just did black yeah they're
just and my homie preacher lawson has a
show called connected yeah
people are doing [ __ ] like i said
nothing good
is out right now i like that show oh
i think it's good i'm sure you enjoy it
nothing good is coming out right now
production is just starting back
it's just like i know atlanta's my
boyfriend grill's filming atlanta
yeah atlanta is like the first one back
he's almost i think a lot of people are
filming out of wait
for show time
white people out here so they're
starting to gear up on productions
yeah yeah uh yeah
cause i i know euphoria they're gonna
release like three special episodes
yeah i think they have like one covet
episode then two
oh that's what i don't need they do
these covid specials get the [ __ ] out
everybody's like doing it through a
computer or something yeah or it's like
the the episodes centered around
cove in the pandemic like what the [ __ ]
show me drugs these kids
the dad who likes to can't do it right
wait what
yes that dad is so fine yeah
he i saw him first time in grey's
anatomy oh yeah he's
so fine who jesse williams the the dad
and euphoria likes this transgender girl
oh he's known as mcsteamy oh no you're
talking about oh yeah there's big dreamy
and there's mick's steaming yeah you see
what i did
thank you yeah i don't know y'all got to
catch it
he looks a lot older now he's a beast in
you i remember when he looked like he's
bodybuilding
euphoria it's like you would love it on
hbo it's like uh high school
just all of these is indeed shoot
zendaya wanna she want to
she wanted she's the youngest person to
win an emmy for
lead actresses she's so good at it yeah
her [ __ ] friend in that movie or that
show
the [ __ ] with the i'm pretty sure
she's of age she's also in once
i'm in hollywood the one with oh yeah um
her name is casey in the show
her like real name is like sydney
sweeney or something oof
she is bad she's a real [ __ ] in the
show
she has a new scary movie that came out
on amazon
we're gonna pretend she's not cross side
here here's the thing
here's the theme
let's pretend she doesn't have two lazy
eyes it's too lazy a [ __ ]
thing i can deal with that
and i will lead you through this journey
we call life
why did she blow it and everything she's
on the one that pulled it up
i saw a pretty picture doing my job
she's gonna pretend her eyes are nice
you know it's funny we really pretended
everyone's gonna ignore it
cat was like oh my god you know it was
real cause keck over the face
she covered her face she's like oh no yo
leave people on their eyes alone
once i'm home from the studio i'm
[ __ ] home but i had a meeting last
night
and i was driving at night and all all
lights had like a
halo around them like all lights were
like my eyes were not 20 20 at night
i think because i had that lasik eye
surgery when i was like 23.
you got to get it done everything either
got to get done or i think i need
nighttime glasses
why not you wear you uh i only wear
eyes aren't great i probably wear my
glasses all the time but i don't i think
i need to
get my eyes checked out because i was
driving i'm like what the [ __ ] is it you
know sometimes
it's like all starry yeah because i i
can usually
since i was a kid i can tell cars from
their headlights yeah i'm like i know
that to fry 488 i know that is
i'm like what's wrong with the lights
because they were like all weird looking
and i drove them i got to 48 i'm like oh
it's not the car it's my [ __ ] eyes i
started looking at other cars i'm like
oh my eyes are [ __ ] up
gotta go get a check yeah and i was also
like damn it's [ __ ] i think your lace
if you do legit you have to go like
every
two years or five years i did it i did
not every 10 years
i think 10 sounds more normal every two
would be a nightmare
but uh oh is it tough no it'd be i think
yeah
every two years that'd be a bad idea and
it's like i remember in venice beach i
saw a sign said lasik
9.99 e no one i wouldn't
do one i get the other one free
are you so serious not 99 100 bucks to
do one night
it's a pandemic brother trying to make
it oh no this is like every 10 years
so it is every 10 years yeah but it says
i need re-treatment you know what i i
don't want to do it i just want to get
uh
i won't i want a reason to wear glasses
you know you know what are your glasses
prescription chin or those for screen
but they're very very light prescription
it's bifocals too
yeah oh they are yes these are for
reading these are for distance
oh i need that i should probably do that
but i feel like yeah but i feel like
i look i can see further away fine but i
need this to read
and my eyes got way worse than the last
like two years so when you're in your
40s
that's when it started 37 doug
wow what the [ __ ] it's like right dorcas
mallorca
no man that's not original
they look cool dude yeah yeah you do
kind of look like a general person it's
like
superman when he takes off his glasses
and has a little like hair thing yeah
like you look different i do you you
look like security for a handleable
burst
yeah flight security yeah i'll take that
it's a good look do they help you yeah
he's a great guy yeah does it help your
eyes
oh my god it's like weird like close
great but like distance it's weird
you look like oldest from martin martin
ooh a little bit yeah yeah
or the best friend from uh get out get
out
yeah the best friend the security guard
oh
yeah you know i do this by side by side
picture yeah i do oh
you do look like hannah but yeah try to
tell me that isn't chappelle
that is chappelle yeah that is true
do a side by side pick again that is you
damn you found your doppelganger
is it me yeah bruh does he have oh i see
what you're saying chin like
it's uh different yeah yeah oh god he
got it yeah like
yeah okay you'll be a great tsa too i
can just tell i would kill that ts dude
i killed it at valet they loved me in
valencia okay you just like valet and
bellman
i would get the nice like uh reviews for
people man
any job i would ever that i ever seen
you have another pair there yeah so
of course um i have only so i have the
you know the bottom
part of the bifocals that's what these
are but they're their entire
hey but when i look down they're great
yeah see that's that's wow
oh because you like the type do you
think you want a thick frame like that
i just i don't know i don't know he's
got to pull it up maybe we should both
go
we should both go it's been it's been i
haven't got my eyes checked since like
27
last night was scary when i was driving
home like oh this ain't good yeah this
is great
yeah i just see clearly like look at i
can see
because there's no way that lasik can
only affect me at night it has to affect
me during the day too i just don't
realize it yet
maybe it's because your eyes are getting
a little worse and then nighttime it's
harder to see i was gonna look at this
fog
foggy i struggle at night how old are
y'all
okay how old are you yeah 28. i just
figured
what did you do hey great junior 40
i just turned 42. yo
yo well first of all
kiss my ass for the way you took that
picture bro bro
that's how you look right he did he he
made me look like that huh
that's how you look hey what what
how long will you pretend chappelle's
not the thickest one let me try those
glasses i'm not the biggest one
do you think it's one item yeah not a
bus chaffel you can't
i'd say you were jay jay-z
look at that
like if you're trying to read your phone
you look like that girl from recess
oh he does let me see
i put his sidebar
did she not have glasses i thought she
had glasses oh wait i don't know
all right well all right well again we
tried which most people think i look
like doug
o'faroo
that's what you look like well there's a
they were going to redo
doug peppermint patty was a baddie
i give some currents man all right
man those kind of [ __ ] my eyes up jen
they're really they're super super weak
though
i know i should i should probably yeah i
should i gotta read i gotta
where you go lens crafters that's still
a thing yeah
minecraft's just still checking your
eyes and then 9.99 you get [ __ ]
glasses yeah something like that six
pairs oh dude
yeah yes we talked about this shortly
yesterday or the other
what do we do with our break quibby is
shutting down after they had i believe
it was
over a billion dollars worth of
investment sent
to this company they ended up going
under belly up
they're the zone of streaming services
exactly what is that a lot of big
they're turning belly up too wow quibby
went down
but uh quick me too they had like kevin
hart movie yeah kevin hart they had to
shoot with them
i like i like the idea 10 minutes and
then it's something next because you
know our attention span is just
like yeah youtube yeah exactly where i
don't have to
and it was like kind of like the worst
timing because like the pandemic it's
like
i want something longer than 10 minutes
so people just going to watch a full
they really thought hey
they try to come up during these guys
binge watching [ __ ] quarantine yeah
shows quarantine and coiby you got
netflix
we see your moves i never got with quick
b you know they always tried to
did they try to please they try to
holler at you uh they wanted to do
something
a while ago yeah and i know theo was
talking with them but it was just like
who
i don't i don't know one person the
building was great though
i'm sure well that's why they went
bankrupt because of their building yeah
i think how much money that building
where was it at
uh probably hollywood yeah yeah
there you go yeah where they had they
had a bunch of candy and [ __ ] like a
bunch of like food like set up where you
got something
you walk in i didn't take no candy [ __ ]
no yeah
i took that water yeah i don't yeah
that's tough tough gig man
so lsu has banned obj
from all facilities for the next two
years because he gave out a hundred
dollar bills
to uh the players
oh you can't do that no you can't give
players money
really man louisiana's so strict who
snitched that
out right it's a hundred dollars on
camera it's on camera
it's a hundred dollars i don't know
what's funny is they give me like a
hundred dollars
it's gonna do anything but they're
giving them cash and then that night lsu
probably made i don't know 120 million
thank you for the for the for
the game for one of the games really
yeah so they make money when a team wins
the championship yeah bcs championship
you make
bank yeah does the coach make oh yeah i
think
everybody hates me except for the
players
you see the players see how rick the
system is come on man
really come on man it's bad it's bad
though they don't give them
what so what do they give these besides
what a scholarship they're saying
educational peep game what if you like a
highlight
meanwhile they help these [ __ ]
they make them take communications
as majors yeah they said usually free
education but imagine you get hurt
and you mess up your knee and you was on
a full ride they don't pay for that yeah
they do they do cover it oh well then
what about your
example well that's a terrible
you example terrible major in whatever
you want right because there are only
like a certain section of classes you
can take
no you can but they really they put they
basically give you your like
i thought you were biggest
yeah they buy the jerseys but but they
could now i think certain guys get
percentage of the jersey sales but again
it's not like life changing
zion people bought manager i mean the
guy who was in duke he went to duke in
order for him to go
to his agent gave him two it gave the
dad 200 grand and a house
and now he's waiting reggie bush got
gifts too yeah so it's like
that's far like i think that happens but
it's [ __ ] up they have to go under the
table if you find out
you're ineligible like reggie bush lost
his heisman trophy hey rick pitino was
giving him uh
strippers oh yeah shout out shout out to
cincinnati
no uh kentucky louisville louisville
louisville there it is
the red and black my bad yeah what else
you got oh my lsu fan
here we go this is the video that was
circulating yesterday it's just a little
boy getting chased by a bird
the bird's just [ __ ] yes the
look at that little foot look at that
little
ah oh
it hit him i still going to hit him
my youngest brother uh hates birds as
well
not a fan of birds but he but they but
they scare him like they scare that
little kid my brother my little brother
you're not [ __ ] here
i feel i mean your kids are going to be
terrified i was like just turn around
and smack
the [ __ ] out of that my brother's 28.
yeah he should be still scared of
birthdays he should be
yeah he's terrified of birds and cats
terrified i just don't like cats i'm not
scared of them i don't like
i think the only person here who likes
birds is chin chin
guys they never really they hate birds
she's had these seagulls in high school
and then they used to [ __ ] on people at
lunchtime my whole girlfriend
that was bad i remember that i was
scared my homegirl's yeah she thinks
pigeons are [ __ ] uh government spots
that's what she said my girl said i mean
not my girlfriend love her shout out to
kylie ostrander show jess ambrose said
the same thing
she said his robot she was like get it
up close and she's like she just
that's where a lot of these conspiracies
come from people just don't know the
[ __ ] they're talking about
and it's easier to jump on board with
concerns she sold me though
yeah i mean you got sold i'm like uh
read the book
yes pigeons are real pigeons are [ __ ]
rich
you know the argument they have for
pigeons
yep i sure have yeah they're out there
if you look google baby pigeon
oh [ __ ] we ain't serious oh [ __ ] okay
people have never seen a great white
give birth
do we think they're spies true oh look a
bunch of baby pigeons
that's what they look like yeah yeah
they're all over new york dude
nobody's look no one gives a [ __ ] about
pigeons they're the rats of the sky
so of course i mean i guess it's like an
easier thing to say
yeah you know it's easier to say oh
they're government spies
yeah i'll tell her to read a book i was
about to say like yeah
they eat bread there's easier ways for
the government to do it man yeah
iphones right sure i'll tell her yeah
i'm like yo you need to just read books
i'll just send i'm just going to send
her send her this clip oh yeah
there's a little segment and then i'll
send her i'll send her a bunch of books
she's great she's got a bunch of books
yeah
they've gone about spying on people i'm
trying to fight for you jess i'm sorry
all right just ambrose as well right
yeah justin bieber
yeah she's just ambrose that was my
friend she said the picture she has
also thought pigeons yeah seriously has
a whole segment on her
podcast and i was on pigeons on pigeons
yeah
you can tell yeah literally she talked
about it and i was like yo
[ __ ] you look at it no her entire
podcast on pigeons no
it was her segment and she convinced us
because they was like they were like you
man stop it there's baby pictures out
there like have you seen the pigeon
uncle and she was like listen
go up to a pigeon look at this uh she
she fooled me she was like yo look at
the eye
it's robotic you know there's a lot of
baby birds i haven't seen
the [ __ ] are just hiding it's
such a stupid argument yeah it's a real
argument now that i think about it
here's what's crazy to hear some [ __ ]
books
christmas is coming up yeah here's
what's crazy scientists they've never
seen a great white give birth
ever never in the history of mankind
they so if you want conspiracy i guess
you could run with that one
well the meg was a good movie yeah they
probably yeah why yeah
why did i listen you're right yeah
you're right because i've never seen a
baby hummingbird
you're right yeah baby hummingbirds i've
been pretty cool looking i know yeah
they fly backwards too i can't yeah
wow i mean it's coming out of its first
ever engine that's not a great white
though
mother shrek gives birth we we can't see
another we've seen
that picture never a great white though
yeah that's also a fake picture
you're better than that he's trying to
bring up demonstrations
what is that get the [ __ ] out get that
shitty photoshop someone did it what's
that wrong on the beach
it was a couple with a short oh
what i've seen okay so i've seen regular
sharks give birth they come out this is
never great white though
yeah every great white oh they come out
killing whales like a little child oh
dude dude on uh world star this morning
i was watching this dude
he has a gopro on and he's in australia
he jumped his boys like three two one he
jumps in the water he's like yeah
and you just see a great white like this
and his friend's like
shark shark and you hear him yelling
underwater straight
up him [ __ ] in the water with a great
white
it's not like a skid like i know which
one you're talking about and they
debunked it
was it what it was like it was like a
regular area right it's not like in the
middle of the ocean
it was like there's like a fence and
he's jumped off of it no go to work near
rocks
it's today go to work
one last time you heard somebody say hey
just go to the world store what we need
a world shark segment
no no no no it's on the it's on the no
no no get out of this okay it's on it's
just on the main page yes scroll down i
love the movie
whoa that was every second though don't
they oh this is no
oh hell yeah wait jason whitlock was
with trump yeah i know right that's
crazy
oh there it is you see that one oh right
there
i bet this is the same one i was
thinking of
yeah see there's a fence oh i knew it
yeah you're right yeah right it's fake
it's fake
why they someone did like an actual oh
where he
like they edit it so it looks like he's
underwater with the shark and then
someone actually did a breakdown
look at this part here this but it looks
so freaking real
on there but it looks so real awesome
it's been ruined it's not like he got
eaten by the shark
but they do it so well it's so freaky
[Music]
first of all terrible acting
that get but look at this this is so
freaky
they need denzel
i don't know yeah
[Applause]
that's real team that's real chin like
watch this
watch what oh how do you edit his legs
oh sh
and it's always these kind of videos
where they're not super clear gopros are
super
clear that's a good point oh all right
chin
it looks really saved the day on that
one i mean it sucks i kind of want it to
be real because it's so cool
hell no that ain't cool to me that being
cool yeah
yeah that is that is kind of tight
usually that's a shout out to the world
yeah that's cool oh hell no dog that's
that listen
i mean it's not cool it's fake oh yeah
if you if you didn't ever tell me that
chant i'm like yo bro
i believe that two sworn houses i know
y'all
in that kind of area australia oh that's
in australia
uh i don't know and sharks should be
pretty much anywhere
oh really especially in the harbor
especially in the sea
especially right here in venice
yes bull sharks are uh not lakes
streets like river rivers well rivers
that go where does that go into
they're in fresh water essentially well
most sharks can swim in
salt and fresh the only shark that can
go salt and fresh
oh they can't uh swim in both they can
they can man i didn't pay attention in
aquaculture
aquaculture yeah aquaculture class yeah
shout out to ellsworth high school mesa
baby aquaculture aquaculture culture it
was like agriculture but
aquaculture and we just studied yeah
that's why we had a bunch of fish that
we took care of yeah that's cool so it's
actually real you're not joking yeah we
had no i'm sorry okay we're great we had
to fillet them and [ __ ]
great yeah they taught us how to fillet
fish what the hell is the cooking class
uh it was an elective so you could you
could be any [ __ ] great i know but
like
i used to sneak out of class when we
watch videos bro he said he never saw me
but help me out here high school college
high school
aquaculture mr road armor what's his
name
that's the road roamer rogue road on
robert got it right you learn how to fly
in high school that's a baby
crosstalk you learn about crustaceans
and mollusk
bro i did not pay attention to that
class that's a great restaurant i just
took care of the fish
i was excited i ate a lot of seafood
there and then i also had
agriculture and we had to take care of
cows and [ __ ]
take care of kyle did you yeah did you
get good grades in it
oh no i [ __ ] around a lot in that
class no i didn't get good grade i
didn't get good grades until
i went i finished at the bad kids school
you know that secondary school
yeah yeah kids have the baby kids are
there yeah all the baby kids
do you realize you're not that bad when
you get there yeah
i was pretty normal and my adopted
father he taught at the school too oh
wow yeah so i'd ride with him to but he
taught the junior high
i was so bad they put they used to put
me in like the special ed class
oh damn night lonnie oh i don't know
what the hell like i get news for you
so they don't put bad kids in space yeah
for bad kids no no because
their hands are bad bad kids
the good news is your friend that
believes pigeons are robots
also in that class
we did the hand turkey and then it was
like yeah
you're probably 16 years old
i wasn't 16. i was i was 13 years old i
was freshman brother
i was so badass because i was bad though
no i was 18
18 years old in a freshman uh english
class bro
it was like the weirdest i was the big
obviously the biggest kid yeah and one
time i cussed at the teacher
because she was like uh i need your
parents to sign something
and it was like around the time like you
know i was mad at my folks yeah oh it
triggered me
i was like i ain't got no got no parents
and she was like you gotta go find
something i said [ __ ] find him for me
and the class was like
he's the curse of my teacher that's so
intense though oh the class didn't know
what to do because he was like hey
little rude on her part to go well you
need to find something i know yeah i
mean i came out of pretty aggressive but
like obviously deserved like oh
don't greet me earlier but then uh hi
malek [ __ ] you too
then the end of the class her and i like
made up oh yeah we made up it was like
actually cool she's
she apologized she goes you know i came
at you and i was like you know you know
she came off all wrong yeah i'm sorry i
called some yeah i was like i'm sorry
i called you a [ __ ] and [ __ ] are we
cool miss accepted she was like hell
yeah and then we like dabbed up like
that
had a whole hand y'all didn't have a
sexual affair hell no
oh i didn't bro hell no why these
teachers look so
bad now but i had the ugly ones growing
up i can't stand that i had these
dragons
i had these warlocks teach me earth
science
i see some of these teachers [ __ ]
with these kids oh my god talk to
you sign me up thank you i'll go back to
the special ed class
i'm talking about awesome i love the 16
year old with a mustache i'm like it was
terrible
she used to suck my dick every day after
class i'm like who's
right thank you thank you thank you
you're living buddy once you get to the
real world
it's crazy that that [ __ ] goes down like
that crazy crazy how about the one
teacher was a dime piece got caught the
kids running a tree train on two of them
i
said you were the trainer you want to
teach you corn balls she was so bad
i'm talking about that's two white boys
yes she got arrested and then the kids
are on the news
we can't believe it we we double
penetrated her
i'm like oh what the hell what that was
me neither you know the bond those two
created thank you
thank you talk to that [ __ ] justin i'm
sitting here writing love albums
your kids are running [ __ ] trains
you're writing love novels
[ __ ] billy and tammy over there doing
double anal
damn no wait no
[Applause]
yeah some of these teachers are like
where are them yeah [ __ ] but i try to
fight my teachers these kids are out
here
freaking running trains and i hate it
what's crazy is the teachers are coming
on to them
yeah really yeah i had new shoes every
day in high school not one teacher got
at me
oh i would i would wear short shorts
dawg i had a teacher named this is
[ __ ] up just hear me
okay it is what it is a teacher named
miss roach and uh
she had shouts out she's so [ __ ] up
her name is miss roach
and she had cancer of her on her face
and it
it took off her nose and like one of her
eyes the monkey jacket so she would wear
a prosthetic
but when you're in sixth grade at royal
hills middle school which is a rough
school
someday she wouldn't put the prosthetic
on so just be like juicy
like hole in her face
and i was next door right so they they
separated by like bookshelves
dude listen nothing but listen to this
where they were turning the light the
lights were off they're like movie time
and she was like you know her face was
gone
and so i was next door like watching a
movie and the kids next door watch the
movie mr rose class
you share hope and she you know she
probably couldn't see out of the eye
tripped over the cord and we just see
her in a wheelchair getting carted off
we're like i did oh my god
shout out to rory hill's look at chin's
face it just feels kind of
get over the you know think about how
big of a distraction
if you're six friends how he just laid
her out like this
like man i wonder what happened and then
sure enough okay yeah
in the world
damn you remember that saying put her in
the casket who put them in the casket
when they fall oh put him over put him
in a coffin right oh yeah people don't
believe
i found a picture of me as a uh in a
high school all right you i'll save it
for cats say forget yeah oh yeah yeah
okay
because it's it's this in this room we
believe you you oh thank you yes
thank you you believe me you guys
believe me i believe i do oh this i
think it's just theo and nick
yeah yeah yeah that's a little ass i
question i question nick's background
yeah out of anybody i know i love nick
you think you think i'm gonna get
adopted into a white family and not
graduate that'll make sense that'll make
no sense that's not how i believe that
did that happen to michael orr
no [ __ ] uh no we got education do you
have no
story what about practice what about
pressure she had monique is a mom
but did brushes get like did a family
take her in i forget precious i've
she stayed in like a a house for like
troubled women afterwards and had her
baby bro how about president that movie
was great it was the movie
she's so she stole my chicken heavy
heavy
you know after that movie came out i got
all these accolades i thought i'd be
booking movie roles
hollywood's racist i'm like i i think
your weight's
the issue here i'm
the book is like no she didn't she did
rose she was on me
she was on me tower heist with eddie
murphy she was on smith or something
like american horror story
type of her imdb no type in news because
she was complaining
about it but i remember that i think
whoever's booking it's like dude we
don't
we don't have a role for a heavyset girl
like just she's on empire
give these letters i'm sorry not that
i'm thinking the other girl
she was on empire my bad give these
heavy savings go to
go to news though you want db or news i
want new [ __ ] imbd
she's working she works there you go
uh whatever name is says the c did not
be part of her career after the oscar
nomination
by the way i mean acting's tough she's
beautiful because you got to rely on
someone saying yeah
oh she said that anna kendrick's career
took off after her oscar nomination but
hers didn't you
you think you as talented as anna
kendrick she's a she's a great actress
like that listen oh wait do you think
anna can you pull up a roll like that
sure so for anna kendrick who was
nominated it had helped her care out but
not mine it's like
you're talking about apples and oranges
like anna kevin
is so [ __ ] talented what's her
catalogue what else she's the voice and
troll she can
sing she's a beast did that
the cup thing in the shadow she was on
that picture pitch perfect
one and two holla trolls one and two
man you talking about some wacky you
know how big trolls is what's how much
she's doing
well emma kendrick that's a bad
comparison because she's multitasking
she can sing and act she's the one that
compared her
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right it's true
all right brendan we're rocking with you
oh i'm thinking of somewhere
i'm all right brendan don't set me up
wait she's uh she was in a teenage
uh move oh she didn't go to her imbd
this tv show old is she i'll look up in
this
i never see this tv show late twenties
a simple favor that's a great who's on
blossom no
troll i think she was too young to be on
blossom the account that's a great
that's a great
uh with matt damon pitch perfect
into the woods what's this tv show i
loved her in
i never watched it it had to be had to
be oh yeah she's the girlfriend and to
watch
his uh jake gentle house girlfriend pair
of norman pilgrim versus the world
50 50 beastie you talking about man i'm
up in the air
yes with george clooney yeah he's great
again how are you going to call her out
though out of all of them it's like yeah
you can you can't she could yes you can
compare you can
or just you shouldn't compare your self
to anybody your journey is different
yeah your
journey is [ __ ] wonderful like you
can't go oh this person
got this and i didn't and i did that as
well but she's awesome
yeah but she's worked a lot too go back
to that uh gabriel
gabby you talking about gabby or uh uh
precious her name is yeah she's doing
she's doing work i mean you gotta be
she was in that i mean uh american
horror story is a big gift
shout out to duran horton you're
scrolling down
you going uh wait her imdb
or what she's complaining this article
she does i saw was that her first major
role
yeah yeah she actually got this role
based off of a
like open casting call like she didn't
act before this this was her first act
wow
that was the same thing for uh fogle and
uh
super bad have you ever seen super bad
you know that
yeah that was just oh she's an
antebellum uh she keeps going it says
i think that's it but i remember that
movie with clint eastwood and the asian
kids
yeah yeah i don't i don't hear about
those kids i don't know about those kids
yeah i love that movie she's in that no
no i'm saying
those those are like also not real
actors but i haven't heard of them since
oh there were real actors no torino i
see that i saw that
i saw the movie the whole thing was
talking about about he had uh maybe
asian neighbors grand trainers yeah
and they were keeping right he made the
kid work for him and stuff to like
because the game oh did you see mule
yeah yeah we kept driving it he was a
cool guy he was
bro driving a drug dealership terrible
and then he wrote it he has a scene
where he hooks up with these two hot
chicks
and he filmed and produced it and
directed it oh really
ends this lead in it i thought it was oh
it's trash
i thought it was complete trash i bought
it you love it
you bought it yeah i like that you
bought it oh you oh you wouldn't got the
dvd
i saw the hp on demand it's a great
movie they don't watch it again
check it out yeah that's good back to
what we're saying yes that's a horrible
comparison yeah there were a couple
other actresses who said the same thing
like halle berry said that after she won
her oscar too like she didn't
yeah she didn't get a bunch of roles
after that and then uh
it is what it is it's like like
different ways acting like stand up like
yeah we just
we have our control to like do it
anytime we want we got that people we
can literally go
oh like if i mean if you're not doing
weekends you can still like go to an
open mic
there's just so many ways to do stand-up
but like when acting you kind of have to
rely on
all these other people to like you know
i don't know give you work yeah say yes
to you yeah here's my thing that's what
you signed up for
true so if you want to cry about it
don't be an actor don't be i'm not being
shitty about it but like you
signed up for that yeah like we're like
you know many auditions i heard no
yeah that's the game i already yeah
that's what you signed up for yeah i
heard a lot
it's like football players like oh my
god you believe we have training cam
like
it's football it's a plethora of changes
like michael phelps be like oh my god
how many laughs i have to swim it's like
yeah [ __ ] you're a swimmer
yeah yeah like these actors just like i
can't like dude it's
it's [ __ ] tough less than i think
0.01 percent of actors make it
like a legit living it's like you know
he's like the highest paid actor right
now
rochester
actress right now i don't remember for a
hot minute i think the highlight
the highest paid for like oh we're like
tv so it was sophia fergara for a while
yeah
don't tell me now i think it's homegirl
she's fine too which one
uh tv show a movie it's a movie
she's so fine she was in uh oh you're
talking about marco robbie
no not at all i know the girl who did
wonder woman too she made so much
was something she's so funny oh i'm
gonna love her fine i'm so stupid she's
too tall for you dog
no she's not just more of my speed she's
16 she's six
six one she's six yeah i'm six too
what are you talking about similar to
somewhere we have to say that
what are you talking about well she said
she didn't like that oh oh she doesn't
she said what if she
made that up oh somebody said i was like
uh
what's her name uh she's such such a big
what movie um
uh hunger games oh jennifer lawrence
jennifer lawrence
for a hot minute she actually beat meryl
streep out of the
barrel street not like physically beat
her but out of austin
you called it uh because of the tv
yeah like usually only three mil tv
actors usually yeah
yeah she's so beautiful wait her in a
person in person
and her man is fine as [ __ ] too the
werewolf yes from
germany yes he's a wolf she got a man
yes
she is a man i think i thought it was ed
o'neill yeah
uh married damn he's a man i love her
accent
i watch modern family just because of
her you know what's weird is like
it's weird to me like mexicans don't
like colombians
accents or vice versa it's weird look at
my baby that's wonder woman right there
though yeah she's the highest paid no
that's her third
ain't nothing like macarthur is that
like a woman she's a big girl she's a
big girl yeah look at melissa mccarthy
yeah i like her shout out take her
i love a woman between her and precious
talent and she's funny
emily blood's [ __ ] great who's emily
blunt oh she was in a
victoria place yes yes there was a quiet
place
quiet place there it is that's what i'm
saying
nicole kidman big little lies and she
got that's right and she got another one
racing out of me grazing i'm still
making money off that they might have a
new season coming up i think it's
interesting oh she she's from uh
handmade tale and invisible man
invisible man
didn't see it oh i started doing corners
viola david okay viola davis
is yeah
i was like where are we coming when they
show the fat
white girl like all right
you still sneak this in there look and
she has talent oh my god
all right with a black girl coming up
please with a black girl follow me
you asking that [ __ ] like a family few
are the next black person on this list
i started to
look at it
it got quiet it got quieter they're
coming it's different this
she has talent she i was like with that
oh she's good yeah she's good she's fine
she's
volunteers thank god hey thank goodness
there's some monsters on that list
though yeah [ __ ]
them girls getting paid man all that
money jennifer lawrence just dipped
after a while though
like i haven't seen people get so much
money they went i've been here for a
while like i respect them like mike
myers
he's like oh i'm done did you make a lot
of those awesome powers
he made a lot of dudes he made a lot of
uh austin powers but he made most of his
money off
shrek off again they didn't really get
paid on the first track the second yeah
murphy never has to work again never
mm-hmm he's gonna do [ __ ]
i love donkey oh he kills mushu too
hell yeah groovy baby yeah mike myers
went i'm good all this
all this how much did you make off that
i said he says he's worth
estimating 175 million goddamn yeah
he'll pop up like you know he was in uh
do you know he was in glorious bastards
uh no he was brad you did like that
small cameo right right right right yeah
he's really small
i don't remember that brad pitt lead
actor in it um yeah
oh he isn't a glorious master yeah what
part
i can't remember i just watched it
recently he's uh
he's he's part of the the british
uh military yes wait that's him
yeah i've never known that he's great
yeah he is he's a great character
like oh michael faster i was thinking
about it uh the other day
um uh who's i was talking with someone i
think my
might have been my girlfriend we were
like talking about who could have done
ace ventura besides jim carrey no one
but did you know
the force gump you know uh bubble gump
they they uh reached out to ice cube to
play bubble gump
wait wait wait and did you know john
travolta was supposed to be forrest gump
and he turned it down
and then tom hanks got it wait really
why did you also
know that tom hanks when they were
filming it they didn't want to pay for
the running scene in one of the other
scenes
and tom hanks went i'll pay for it but
if it does well you got to give me this
much money and then went yeah cool this
movie's probably not going to do that
well
so he made like double bed oh dude
because he paid for the run scene in
another scene he got
in different states yeah yeah so and he
goes i'll front it
but i i want this percentage on the back
end and they signed off that dude i
cried at the bubble gum scene
man life was like every time that movies
dude can we talk about jenny being a
horse i hate jimmy
wrecked his whole life with that door
just starts
off just good we talking about good guys
look how these women break dudes yeah
come on yes yeah
i'm alive from the mark i love it when
he whips that guy's ass right and then
they kick him out of the black panther
meeting and them
he's so stupid and then the next days
are getting on the bus
and uh she he's all jenny i love you and
she's like foreign
and she's like we're gonna go and he
looks at me he's all to green bow
alabama
and then just keep stammies all
i love that movie that movie was great
he went he won oscar out there correct
right
i think he won every award everyone
changing yeah that was great movie was
[ __ ] great
oh the big story of tom hanks paying for
certain
uh scenes like made him rich beyond
belief yeah he won everything
which it should and you said
philadelphia with him and denzel is a
great one dude
denzel's so good in that yeah i got oh
deal drops the f bomb in that a bunch
the word that rhymes with
rhymes with rags with maggots he rhymes
with maggots he drops the f-bomb a lot
oh oh cause of the aids and because at
first he doesn't like like gay dudes
he's like man i'm not trying to blah
blah with maggots and then
by the end of it he's like the number
one supporter it's dope oh wow that's
cool i gotta watch it yeah that's a
great
guy uh goodwill hunting have you ever
seen milk
uh with uh sean penn true story it was a
guy who's running for office in san
francisco he's a
first gay guy to run for office in san
francisco he ends up a spoiler but also
history so not a spoiler he gets
assassinated no
mm-hmm oh damn that's cool he's like
fighting for gay rights he's in san
francisco during haight ashbury times
have you seen it chin
no i remember the story though oh crazy
it was a harvey something like a real
guy
milk milk okay in the 70s i think oh
really
it's like in the heat like every there's
protests everything and
cops used to come into the gay district
and just beat the [ __ ] out of people for
being gay
damn yeah harvey milk
sean penn's so good in that his
boyfriend's uh
uh homeboy that did uh disaster movie
how does sean look at
him because he kind of i could see sean
sean uh yeah pulling that off
oh sean penn looks a spot on and he's
yeah i can see him like look dude his
voice pl
it's crazy how green wow that is kind of
crazy
a great movie man oh wow yeah it's
fascinating too he's in san francisco
he's fighting for gay rights
all right i got some movies to watch
check it out dude that and goodwill
hunting in philadelphia i'm gonna watch
philadelphia
i'm gonna watch philadelphia milk you
should watch straight out of compton
i bet i've seen more movies than you
guys i'm a movie connoisseur i love
movies
you haven't seen you ever seen angus oh
no yeah we talked about this i've never
seen eggs
you don't want to go see anger you're an
[ __ ] dude i recommend
philadelphia and melch and you
recommended angus what is true
i think this is great angus bethune
come on now you ever seen baby boy yeah
baby boys
[Laughter]
give me one more all right i gotta pick
up my son soon
yours cat okay wait
this might not work so let's go
let's go here actually send it to me
okay so
a manchester united uh player aaron juan
basaka uh his girlfriend dumped him
recently
because his side chick came out and
basically aired out all of his dirty
laundry saying that she's been
[ __ ] him on the low and he has a baby
coming out with a third woman
and they did this this is a u.s
model um this is the side piece that's
his girlfriend her name's rihanna
oh my gosh but yeah this is a side chick
and we
are now waiting to figure out who the
third person is because
he's got another side chick yeah the
other side chick is pregnant and he does
not want the child
his ads are he plays for man united
women she's not going
anywhere he makes money he does uh he's
he's like your premier league player you
don't make money
what does he make they get they're the
highest paid the highest point i think
he just got
a deal for 55 million euros
would be for one year right like more
than like a baseball player
yeah they're the premier league sport
that makes the most money yes
are you serious he looks like a good guy
keep a clean haircut he looks like
he looks he's has also been linked to
another player
on his team as well as the ra a rapper i
think playboy cardi
who got who uh iggy azalea baby uh daddy
yeah i think it's that it's one of the
lower rappers
she had a child she had a baby boy
really yeah
who's the daddy uh playboy cardi party
playboy there's so many people when she
was with uh swaggy p
yeah yeah and then uh russell yeah
oh wait no she dated sway lee sway lee
oh
that's a baby with from ray schwermann
uh no uh the side chick was also [ __ ]
with swaley
damn
i'm looking at that i'm looking at that
i'm looking at that
look how bad she is they should have put
the baby mama first and then that one
they did that dirty they
look at the picture they chose of her
she looked like she's getting ready to
say something
is that this is a wholesome photo the
other one is that's not even she looks
like she's about to talk
wait time let's give her let's give her
the benefit of doubt can we go to the
instagram page that's all i want to know
don't don't go the side pieces i just
yeah i'm not going to i cannot stop it
so bad yeah wouldn't be [ __ ] dude's
lifestyle
it's not fair anymore ugh let's see what
the baby mom look like and then i'm off
it
she don't have an instagram oh she
probably uh let's see if this works
she'll probably put on private now
i think that's her yeah but private okay
okay she could look at her
yeah they're gonna gotta they gotta
gotta go you gotta got a better bag
that's amazing
yeah they're gonna do the side pieces
is that weight there's a better one oh
gosh i mean she's not bad looking she's
[ __ ] trying man
yeah things are wrong with her she's
[ __ ] trying let that man live fathers
be good to your daughters
is what it roots back your bubble gum
tongue girl
oh that's her when she was younger
probably again she's [ __ ] trying
in the streets oh gosh hashtag good guy
yeah he has 55 million euros in his
pocket thank you
dick thank you the only mistake he made
is he got a chick pregnant he should
have strapped up that's the only
mistake he made you're making 50 points
he got the side piece pregnant
no he got the side side side side side
he got side side piece right so you mean
he already has a baby with the his
actual girl i know he doesn't have
have a family with girl and then gets
the side piece
squared pregnant you know yeah god side
p
squared five p squared look at that w
i guess i was fine i can't believe you
don't dab it up on the heavy
dog you went
yeah much love to her uh boise tickets
just went on sale december 5th
once you're only with me and these boys
with a z
boise idaho one night only one show
december
5th in boise idaho uh and then
phoenix november 5th through the 7th
those tickets are most sold out get
tickets now
my dad's coming yo papa's coming hell
yeah
tfatkay.com phoenix then also nashville
november 19th
21st boise december 5th get tickets now
tfatkay.com
thick boy gear get your thick ass some
gear uh thickboy.com jerseys just got
restocked we got some dope [ __ ] dropping
the end of the mud
so get it chappelle you're in tempe
uh the thanksgiving the dates
thanksgiving
yeah november 27th through the 29th i'm
headlining tempe improv though
poppin what's poppin brand new whip just
hops in yeah yeah um
i got the i got uh all at chapellacy.com
i know we're working on we're actually
getting your [ __ ] uh spellacy.com
for all that [ __ ] you know support
support uh
black business
[Laughter]
biola davis sorry dude
she just shot me
all right we're out